am donnerstag springen 120 militär
fallschirmspringer über wiener neustadt
aus zwei c 130 hercules maschinen ab
grund dafür ist ein jubiläum 60 jahre
militär fallschirmsprung
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
betont die wichtigkeit dieser elite
einheiten des punktes harris und der
polizei der lehrgruppe
fallschirmspringen bildet seit vielen
jahren nicht nur die jagd
kommandosoldaten aus sondern auch
soldatinnen soldaten des jägerbataillons
25 der militärakademie der jahres und
offiziers akademie und auch die kräfte
des einsatzkommandos
darf ich weiterhin viel erfolg wünschen
viel erfolg bei der ausbildung beim
training und im einsatz und das
wichtigste bleiben sie alle gesund